they're popular in Hollywood and we've
all seen them before the art heist film
the movies involve elaborate schemes to
steal priceless paintings jewelry and
artifacts it's over 6 pounds of diamonds
but they're not very realistic I think
people think they think it's sexy this
is Robert Wittman he spent 20 years with
the FBI's national art crimes team
helping to recover more than 300 million
dollars worth of stolen pieces he told
us that these heist films are far from
how these heists go down in real life
while each of these movies has its own
twists and turns films like 1999's the
Thomas Crown Affair and 2018 ocean's 8
follow a pretty similar formula a
mastermind decides what to steal from
where they may act alone or assemble a
team of specialists perfectly suited for
their mission the glamorous criminals
crack an uncrackable safe or cleverly
sneaked past the guards to remove the
valuable items the thieves butt up
against the law enforcement officers
trying to track them down or stop them
turns out these movies get every single
one of these aspects wrong let's start
from the beginning so location of the
heist movies like ocean's 8 aren't all
wrong oftentimes heists do take place in
museums just not usually the big ones
like the met art theft is more likely to
take place at smaller museums or
historical societies where security
isn't so tight and the success rate is
higher it's much more difficult to get
through the security system at the Met
or at the Louvre it is to get it through
a small house museum it's a whole
different situation so while there have
been thefts in the past from these
places they are rare who are the thieves
and we found that 90% in the United
States were done in-house in other words
someone who had access to the collection
could have been a worker there or
curator or even a expert going in and
you know doing their research so they're
not typically the Thomas Crown type no
sharply dressed billionaire with a
passion for art and a lot of free time
on their hands just someone who has easy
access on a daily basis how they pull
off the heist in heist films you often
see Thebes
hacking security systems weaving through
laser beams or lowering themselves down
from the ceiling but this is a bit
extreme usually it's a crime of passion
or a crime of opportunity it's quick in
quick out usually breaking doors not not
going through security systems
I'm not turning things off this sort of
heist wouldn't make a very long or
interesting film but it's much more
likely
well the Met claims to have a very
sophisticated security system in place
it's also not quite what you see in the
Thomas Crown Affair and Thomas Crown
Affair they had the moveable walls
closing up the beatings at the Museum I
think that a sprinkler system or
something going on as well with water
coming down that use not what's gonna
happen in a museum I don't know if any
museum that has moveable walls that come
together the pursuit law enforcement
isn't as dumb as they might come off in
the movies when it comes to tracking
down the stolen works and cops will
often spend a lot of time undercover
with the criminals to recover the stolen
art there are less armed robberies of
art in the United States than in Europe
where thieves have a few advantages the
countries have open borders are very
close to one another so it's easy to get
away and the security systems and one of
the older museums are just based
basically outdated regardless of the
location once the art is stolen it's
actually nearly impossible to sell it
it's not as simple as waltzing to the
black market and finding a seller
especially if it's a famous piece for
example the Mona Lisa was actually
stolen in 1911 by a man named Vincenzo
Peruggia he hid it at his home for two
years before trying to sell it to a
curator who eventually turned him in to
the police there was also a heist in
2000 at stock Holmes National Museum in
Sweden by robbers armed with
machine guns Whitman set his own trap
with the thieves who tried to sell more
than 30 million dollars worth of art by
Rembrandt and Renoir he set up a deal to
buy the pieces for just two hundred and
fifty thousand dollars it took him five
years and all they found these thieves
all they found were the police that were
interested in buying it instead of
selling the pieces thieves will
occasionally use stolen paintings as
bargaining chips who cops as a sort of
get-out-of-jail-free card in the end all
of that work and planning you see from
thieves and movies is typically all for
naught so really it's a silly crime to
commit and we all lose when a piece of
art is stolen says Whitman stealing a
MANET is much different from stealing a
Chevrolet the Chevrolet can be recovered
or it can be replaced you cannot replace
a MANET or a Rembrandt once it's gone
it's gone and we all suffer that loss
[Music]